California judge Aaron Persky is
speaking out only to CBS this morning
one week before voters decide if he
should be removed over his handling of a
sexual assault trial he gave former
Stanford University swimmer Brooke
Turner a short jail term after Turner
was found guilty of assaulting an
unconscious woman the sentence generated
global outrage it also raised questions
about judicial independence and politics
in the courtroom John Blackstone spoke
to the judge about the controversial
sentence John good morning good morning
judge Erin Persky has remained largely
silent as the campaign to remove him
from the bench has built over nearly two
years now but now in his only television
interview he's defended the sentence
that has been so widely condemned if a
judge is thinking in the back of his or
her mind how is this going to look how
will it look on social media will I be
vilified on cable news that's the wrong
Avenue we can't do that we shouldn't do
that burski sentencing of brock Turner
meant the former Stanford University
swimmer walked free after spending just
three months in county jail for sexually
assaulting an unconscious woman you did
have some idea before you passed the
sentence that it would be a
controversial sentence yes and by my
ethical constraints by the rule of law I
had to completely tune that out in court
Turner heard the words of his victim a
powerful statement that was widely
shared on social media you took away my
worth my privacy my confidence she told
Turner I don't want my body anymore I
was terrified of it if this case were
before you today the me2 movement being
what it is might you have been more
sensitive to the feelings of the society
around you well let me say again on
based on the code of judicial ethics I
can't really discuss the details of the
case or my my decision-making but I can
say that generally the answer is
absolutely not
judge burski sentencing of Turner
followed the recommendation of the
county probation department the
California Commission on judicial
performance concluded there is not clear
and
convincing evidence of bias or judicial
misconduct when we make a decision in
the civil or criminal case we're always
disappointing one side or the other and
so if one side or the other that's
disappointed is able to generate outrage
get it out there on social media raise a
lot of money based on one decision it
just it's just not right
a million people signed an online
petition calling for persky's removal
from the bench the recall campaign has
raised more than a million dollars he's
raised about four hundred thousand to
fight back
there are even lawn signs now that have
my face next to a mug shot of the
defendant certainly for a while you seem
to be the most hated man on the Internet
probably so I accept responsibility for
every decision that I've made as a judge
but what I cannot accept are the
downstream consequences the collateral
damage if you will to the next case to
the next judge's decision to even the
next jurors decision I mean this notion
the power of social media the power of
politics if it affects jurors then where
are we we've completely corrupted our
system four weeks after he sentenced
Turner judge Persky said he had to come
and go from this courthouse using the
back entrance I usually reserved for
inmates since the recall effort began he
hasn't been hearing cases here he's been
working only as a Night Court judge gale
all right John Blackstone thank you it's
good to hear from him a lot of people as
John pointed out he was certainly
vilified it's interesting to hear his
thought process behind the decision and
and this is a this is a judge where
voters vote them in and get them out and
that's that's the power of your vote and
the voters will get a chance to weigh in
on this